what up guys today's gonna be super cuny
day because um it's a me
and tiger day papa is in california and
um tyke has been sick oh my god there's
been so much going on with tiger's
health especially because this is first
year with other students so he's just
getting all the germs and i'm telling
you we've been in and out of urgent care
er and just pediatrician's office
okay so
it's been a month uh i'm trying to do
the math here at least 10 times it's
been nuts and then they've called us
from his school
to pick him up because he's been
coughing excessively or like just health
things happening all the time and
granted tych is a super healthy kid like
none of us have any crazy like health
issues um we're really fortunate oh what
is going on okay wait wait
hi cutie what's happening did you tie
your shoes yes
good job
i have to teach you how to tie your
shoes okay but this looks really good
already you're off to a good start duty
okay so you've been sick today you're
supposed to go to school but you didn't
go to school
because why
yeah you've been coughing a lot but
you're not even sick anymore the only
thing is that you're coughing
because you've had bronchitis before
anyway that's beside the point you're so
cute
we're going to tire again to get a toy
okay why are you why are we going to
target to get a toy why do you why do
you get a toy because that's it
that's that way that yes and we told you
you earned that you earned it right we
told you last week that if you're a good
boy
yeah that if you're a good boy and you
follow all the rules and you do go in
jiu jitsu and you do good at school
and you pick up by your mess then we're
going to take you to target to get the
toy that you wanted right yeah okay well
it's been a week and we got to keep our
promise
let's go
and i would also like to point out come
on dude stop doing that that taika
dressed himself
what made you pick this close
yeah but what was the thought what were
you thinking when you got it how come
you didn't put shorts on because
they should call for me oh okay good job
okay let's go
look at these fluffy clouds oh my god it
looks like a painting look at that that
is gorgeous
it looks like a big crocodile yeah
do you guys see a big crocodile
i see what do i see what does it look
like to me
well that right there looks like a
little elephant
that right there
above the clouds
what else it just looks like a painting
to me
so we are at tyka's favorite toy store
or
cvs
monkey this isn't even a toy story
little monkey monkey okay go show me
where your toy is i'll follow you
okay
oh cool
okay
where's your toy that you want
i'll follow you
cool stuff
[Music]
[Music]
okay hold on pause
okay go i'll follow
or
baseball
hello
oh that's
[Music]
[Applause]
i think it's down there by your knees
did you just kiss that no he's a cutie
pie is it that one
you only brought 20 dollars
i can get two toys well it has to be 20
bucks i'll show you okay what do you
want to look at first
that one's 40 bucks i'll spot you
are you gonna buy me this or not
maybe what else what else are you
looking at
let's see what happens let's see what
happens let me just let's just look
whoa
oh yeah it's cool
[Music]
[Music]
okay so which one one or the other this
one is 17
the other one was this one's 40 dollars
you can only have one
i want this one want the cars you want
more cars
yeah okay
we'll go put it back then
yeah but you only have enough money for
one
[Music]
let's see let's look at it okay taika
yeah why do you want this one what does
it have that's cool
oh
yeah like the new one
yeah
i want the only need to change his
costume yeah
oh and then it has a web shooter
i got you yeah
okay what about this one why do you want
this one
this one is just this okay
as one card it's just this
so just gonna lift it up it doesn't
shoot or do anything
no
but this
but have to have a picture of the other
cars
it has like pictures
this picture what do you think you're
gonna play with more this one
or this one this one and this one no ah
you can only pick one
why need to pick one
because that's all you brought enough
money for
but i don't want to pick one i know dude
a lot of us don't want to pick one thing
this one which
one whoa
that's it you sure
[Music]
nice good call let's go then
you like it yes
spiderman
i'm checking out doctor timmy's to mess
with his box
okay now we're going to real target
because i have to buy a shirt for your
school okay dude it's green a green one
don't even pinch me exactly a green
shirt for no one to pinch you
yeah i usually have all this stuff ready
for taika but like
i don't know i don't really think of st
patrick's day not really but i guess out
here they really do celebrate it i guess
schools in general should celebrate it i
don't think it's out here type of thing
um
and for the past couple of like free
days and just like days where they don't
have to wear a uniform because taika
school is required to have all the
students who are uniforms i forgot and
there's been a couple times where um
he's been the only kid
wearing his uniform and i know he
doesn't really care i think it's more me
and i'm making it a bigger deal than
what it is but i also want to get out of
the house and i'm also going to test out
to see how his throat is so far he
hasn't coughed
and the severe coughing
um is what had him
get sent home from school so
okay i'm just making an excuse i just
want to get out of the house and i just
want to go to target okay
but let's see if i can like
not buy [ __ ]
we'll keep it at that
but i think i can do it
emphasis on i think
okay so now we are at target in the
little boys section and they have so
many cute clothes out here
but we're not here to look at that we're
here to get tyka a green shirt for st
patrick's day
i'm gonna show you the first one
minecraft
minecraft
minecraft
oh there's the cough
it's only there
do you guys show me not you
show me
you guys see that
the hedgehog
dude you want to dress like a dinosaur
no
uh look at all these cute little pajamas
you did see this one that you thought
was really cute
look at that it comes with little
footsies
you have a lot of underwears
that's not your size though
you wear boxer briefs oh these are boxer
briefs oh can i have this one
that's not your size that's way too big
i think you're a six
maybe i want this one yeah but your butt
it's not gonna fit you you're not an
eight you're i think you're six i think
you're this one
you're gonna try it in minecraft
no that's oh that might i think you're a
six you want to get these
four you're four years old but you're
not for size that's different
okay so getting a sweater for tyka now
because the ones he's wearing are a
little too thick here how are you
supposed to put on a sweater what do you
do with your sleeves
okay now put your hand in
and i like to buy them one size bigger
and we're still at target
and they have like the coolest stuff you
hold on to that sleeve
no no just leave in your hand
there you go
let me see
is this one too big now
i think it's too big we'll get this
small
okay dude
rude stop it
what are you doing okay go go you want
to show the camera
you wanna do it again yeah okay well
taika just surprised me with something
go
in the car you kept saying you were so
hot and i didn't understand why
[Music]
okay take off your pants
why do you have your pajama pants to
watch did you say that oh what am i
supposed to say
okay okay
no wonder you are hot you're supposed to
take up whoa
you're supposed to take off your pajama
pants duty
don't pull down your underwear dude
that's not funny just take off your
pants please
such a troll man
you're definitely your father's i mean
son yeah your father's son i said it
right take off your pants i got to see
if these pants fit you
i like these six regular they didn't
have i mean the fours there look kind of
small oh these are levi's okay target
okay go
i'll put this up just in case oh there
you go
i don't trust you i feel like you're
gonna show something you're not supposed
to show okay you know what you're making
me nervous
did you even take your pajamas off
they're here too
you have your pajamas over no wonder you
were so hot you had so much clothes on
okay so those pants kind of fit you big
[Music]
[Applause]
and the other end of the jam on the
couch is
toby oh toby i'm gonna put him down oh
okay hey what do you want to drink
um
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah i don't take it and him they're
fighting with the horns but it is so but
but don't have claws oh don't have dust
i see the only doctor came back oh yeah
he has less claws
you got another you got another